and god spake all these words saying
i am the law thy god which have brought
thee out of the land of egypt
out of the house of bondage thou shalt
have
no other gods before me thou shalt not
make unto thee
any gritten image or any likeness of
anything
that is in heaven above or that is in
the earth beneath
all that is in the water under the earth
thou shalt not bow down thyself to them
nor serve them for i the lord thy god
am a jealous god visiting the iniquity
of the fathers upon the children
unto the third and fourth generation of
them that hate me
ensuring mercy unto thousands of them
that love me
and keep my commandments thou shalt not
take the name of the lord thy god in
vain
so the lord will not hold him guiltless
that
taketh his name in vain remember the
sabbath day
to keep it holy six days shall thou
labor and do all thy work but the
seventh day
is the sabbath of the lord thy god in it
thou shalt not do any work thou
not thy son nor thy daughter thy
manservant
nor thy maidservant nor thy cattle nor
thy stranger
that is within thy gates for in six days
the lord
made heaven and earth the sea and all
that in them is
and rested the seventh day wherefore god
blessed the sabbath day
and hallowed it honor thy father and thy
mother
that thy days may be long upon the land
which the law thy god giveth thee
thou shalt not kill thou shalt not
commit adultery
thou shalt not steal thou shalt not bear
false witness against thy neighbor thou
shalt not covet thy neighbor's house
thou shalt not covet thy neighbor's wife
nor his manservant
nor his maidservant nor his ox nor his
ass nor anything that is
thy neighbors and that passage of
scripture from exodus 21 to 17
represents the whole duty
of man there is nothing god requires of
you
or of me that falls outside
of the ten commandments all his
requirements somehow
are encompassed by that standard
of eternal righteousness god bless those
of you who still with us
if those who endure unto the end with
the same shall be saved
so i'm grateful to those who are still
with us we're close to the end and it
has not really been
that long but let me again welcome in a
very special way
anyone listening you just joined in you
are not
a set of the adventist thank you very
much
for your presence i mean that genuinely
i mean the lord blessed your lives in a
very special way
if you're considering becoming a
seventh-day adventist that is the
heavenly urge that god has placed on you
follow it act on it do not delay
we would love to have you not just as a
guest
but as a member of the church family so
thanks again
and god bless you let go i asked god to
bless the south botswana conference in a
very very special way
we thank god for them and for the other
conference in botswana
for the work in that country generally
and for the work in all countries
represented
by this listening audience i want to
pray now that god will bless this
presentation and whatever is left
of this night of prayer but before i do
i ask you once again
preserve reverence where you are the son
may have said i'm sure it has
where you are but remember the sun never
sets on your personal holiness
it sets on a day not on people
and so seven days a week 24 hours a day
you and i are required to be holy so
there's no sunset on our individual
holiness
so please preserve reverence where you
are because god is
always god regardless of the format
by which we worship him favor number two
while i'm speaking pray for me and say
lord
put your words in that man's mouth
prophets and kings
6 26 ella white writes the words of the
bible and the bible alone should be
heard from the pulpit
this is an electronic pulpit i wish to
speak god's words ask him
to put his words in my mouth jeremiah 1
verse 9 then the lord put forth his hand
and touched my mouth and the lord said
unto me behold i have put my words
in thy mouth when god said moses to
speak to pharaoh god told moses
exodus 4 12 now therefore go
and i will be with thy mouth and teach
thee what thou shalt say
and fear number three think as you
listen
thinking is not always an automatic
activity
think apply the mind god has given you
think of what you're hearing and the
spirit of god will bless that activity
isaiah 1 18 come now let us reason
together set the lord let us pray
father in heaven thank you again for
this time of
prayer and worship and fellowship
and the spoken word we thank you for
those who organize this very very
vital program dear god we need more of
it
as we continue towards the end we ask
that your spirit will continue to direct
and guide and oversee all that we do
that you may be glorified father and we
blessed
if we've offended you forgive us dear
god forgive us
that's why jesus died i pray lord for
those listening who are not certainly
having this
touch their lives touch them god
with the scepter of truth that they may
er long
become one of us father if someone
listening to me
has contracted the coronavirus i call
upon you in the name of jesus
and because you are also merciful god
heal
that person by god whatever affliction
may be causing distress for your people
touch them father give them relief that
they may be reminded
that they serve a merciful god father
bless your people in botswana the host
country
and in all other countries represented
by those who listening
bless those who organize this day of
prayer this night of prayer
now speak through me i pray please in
jesus name
amen in
first samuel chapter 1 verse 10
first samuel chapter 1 verse 10 and on
the issue of prayer
i will bring three things to your
attention one that we ought to pray with
earnestness
two we ought to pray without ceasing
and the three we ought to pray through
the word of god
we ought to pray earnestly you ought to
pray without ceasing
we ought to pray through the word of god
first samuel 1 verse 10
hannah the mother-to-be of samuel
was barren she had no children she was
one of two wives
and she was very very much distressed by
her inability
to give birth to a child being barren
back at any time in history
being buried is viewed as a curse i said
it is view
it is not a curse it is viewed as a
curse and it is worse in some cultures
hannah was greatly distressed that she
could not have children
so when she went with her husband to a
feast she
chose to pray to god and the bible says
in verse 10
of 1st samuel 1 and she was in
bitterness of soul
and prayed unto the lord and wet sore
now this is the kind of praying that we
need in these last days
as we are on the very edge of that time
of trouble
such as the world has never seen we need
to
pray in such a way it almost sounds like
a matter of
life and death the way jacob prayed at
midnight
when that stranger touched his shoulder
and he thought it was someone sent by
esau to kill him
and he began to fight for his life and
he wrestled with god
and he realized it was god and god said
let me go and he said i will not let it
go except that blessing he held onto god
even though god dislocated one of his
hips he would he fought god on one leg
this is the kind of praying we need
praying that is earnest
and so the bible says of this woman who
greatly desired a child
she was in bitterness of soul and
prayed into the lord and wept so
she wept bitterly and there is a time
when we ought to pray
and cry as we pray jesus did that
we look at him in a minute let's go to
isaiah chapter 38
we read from verse one isaiah 38 reading
from verse one
in those days was hezekiah sick unto
death
and isaiah the prophet the son of amos
came unto him
and said unto him thus said the lord set
thine house in order
for thou shalt die and not live
how would you like it if the minister
for health in your country
or your town came to your house at
midnight knocked on the door and told
you told you
you would be dead by tomorrow morning
how would you like it if someone
announces your imminent death
isaiah the prophet and prophet spoke
with heavenly authority
isaiah told uh hezekiah right to his
face
looking him right in the eye this is
what god said
you will die and you won't live
having heard that the bible says then
hezekiah turned his face towards the
wall
and prayed to the lord and said remember
oh
lord i beseech thee how i have walked
before the in truth
with the perfect heart and i've done
that which is good in thy sight verse
three ends this way
and hezekiah wept sir
he cried as he prayed hannah first
samuel 10
1 verse 10 she cried the words are
precise
she wept saw hezekiah wept sore
let's go to jesus hebrews chapter 5
verse 7 let's pray again father as i
continue
remind me i am here for your glory first
and foremost
in jesus name i pray amen
hebrews chapter 5 verse 7 speaking of
jesus the bible says
who in the days of his flesh when he
offered up prayers
and supplications with strong crying and
tears
and to him that was able to save him
from death and was heard
in that he feared jesus offered the
prayers
and supplications with strong crying
and tears this is
earnest praying so that heaven realizes
that you're serious this is not a
formula you walk down the street
you see a friend you say hi how are you
doing and you proceed with your business
praying from the foundation of the soul
in
bitterness of soul like hannah facing
death
like hezekiah facing death like jesus
or having to carry the burdens of the
world's sin like christ
you pray from the very depth of your
soul
and that kind of praying moves heaven
and so hannah prayed and cried
and god answered her hezekiah prayed
and cried that the bible says in isaiah
38 of verse
4 then the word of lord came to isaiah
saying go and say to hezekiah
thus said the lord the god of naked
david thy father
i have heard thy prayer i have
seen thy tears and i say to you who are
listening to me
what is god seeing when you pray show
god something where this tears
a sensei heart which you should always
see let
god see something we know god knows
everything but we're talking in human
terms
show god when god told abraham to
sacrifice isaac genesis 22 abraham rose
up early in the morning
sat in his ass took two of his young men
with him took isa
cut the word for the burnt offering he
started journeying he came to the place
he built the oil to put the water in
isaac and he took the knife he tied up i
said he did all of that
then the angel said stop and god said
now i know
that unfair is god now i know now god
has always known
but god is speaking in terms we can
understand and i see to you
show god something when you're praying
let him see you're serious and this
is not just a routine activity in which
you've engaged all your life and so it
becomes a habit
well some habits are good but praying
must be a conscious
intentional habit not just one that
takes over automatically
hannah prayed and cried hezekiah prayed
and cried and god told isaiah tell
hezekiah
i have heard thy prayer
i have seen thy tears behold i will add
on to thy days
15 years when we pray
we must pray with earnestness we must
learn
to wrestle with god as jacob rustled
we must learn to wrestle with god as
hannah russell
and hezekiah russell yeah as jesus
christ wrestled with his father
we must learn to pray with earnestness
this effective this this effective
fervent prayer
of the righteous man avails much james 5
7 16 the effectual fervent prayer
that's similar to what hannah did
similar to what hezekiah did
and similar to what jesus did the
effectual
fervent and the word for was just fiery
it's intense
it's from the very foundation of the
soul that is struggling
when the prayer arises from that place
as i said earlier heaven is moved here's
what i mean
get a call from the school where your
child is attending
and you learned your child fell off a
roof and he's in a coma in a local
hospital
and you have to pray now how will you
pray
or you got a call from your boss you've
been working for some big company price
waterhole cooper
and you thought your future was secure
you got a mortgage for a house
you got a loan for two cars you got a
loan for your children's tuition
and then you got a call saying you've
been fired we're downsizing
and you collapse on your knees and you
begin to pray
how will you pray casually
we're in the last days of verse history
as i said earlier
we are on the very verge of the great
time of trouble
we're in the verge of the severless
splays we're on the verge of the sunday
law we're on the verge of persecution
how will we pray let's pray with
earnestness
sometimes let's pray with tears to let
god see
the sincerity and the intensity
with which we come before him too many
prayers are simply
conversational there is a place for that
but that's not what should characterize
our prayers
intensity earnestness a
concentrated seriousness should
distinguish
our prayers to god and so i said i'll
talk about the earnestness of prayer
and i have dealt with that let's look at
praying without ceasing
first thessalonians 5 17 the bible says
pray
without ceasing this is not a symbolic
text
it is literal it is real and it means
precisely what it said
now the verse does not say kneel without
ceasing
it says pray without ceasing
this is the kind of lifestyle that
must be developed by constant
disciplining of the mind
by that i mean you and i with the help
of the spirit of god
can train our minds to engage
in prayer all during the day
and i repeat and i italicize and i
underline
and i write in bold prank all during
the day it can become as natural to us
as breathing you get into your
car you start praying
you're on the bus you pray
you're jogging you pray you're in the
classroom
you pray you're in the market you pray
in other words you are always in contact
with god
you go off the tour some nature park the
okavango
you pray as you're out in nature you see
the sunlight you see grass you see a
bird
what you pray everything around you
tells you talk to god pray
without ceasing you're frustrated
you pray someone compliments you
you pray a friend of mine texted me once
i am stuck
in terrible traffic and i texted back
pray god may have arranged for you to be
stuck in traffic
to give you time to pray because you
cannot find enough time outside of
traffic
so he placed you in traffic no amount of
getting angry can move the car ahead of
you or the one behind you
so god has placed you in a position
where you cannot go backward or forward
so that you might pray
pray with earnestness pray without
ceasing
and there's difference between prayer
that's ceasing and praying with
determination there's what i mean
yes we pray all day but sometimes
requests we bring to god are not
answered because we give up too quickly
and we move on to something else let's
go to matthew 26
44. this is christ in the garden of
gethsemane
matthew 26 44 i'll pray again father
continue to speak through me as i speak
to those whom you love
in the name of jesus christ i pray amen
and he left them and went away again
and prayed the third time saying the
same
words now this is not vain
repetition this is constantly presenting
a petition to god
because you are serious and you will not
give up the bible says
and he went away and he left them
and went away again and prayed the third
time
saying the same words
very often as i said prayers are not
answered because
we give up too quickly now the purpose
of praying is not to manipulate god
some people believe faith is believing
god will do whatever i say
no that sounds like uh arrogance that
sounds like presumption
faith is not believing that god will do
whatever you say
faith is believing that god will always
keep his word and thus said the lord is
absolutely reliable but faith is
absolutely not believing that god will
do what you say or i say no no
faith cometh by hearing and hearing by
the word of god
so when we pray with determination we're
not trying to manipulate god
we are praying believing that god will
be faithful to his word that's why the
bible says in john 15 7
this is jesus christ if you abide in me
and my words abide in you you shall ask
what he will
and it shall be done unto you if he
abide in me
and my words in you which means it is
essential for us
to pray through the word of god to pray
biblically in other words
let's say you're praying for someone
who's sick
you come to god it is not enough to say
father can you heal my friend
either my brother heal my spouse heal my
child heal whomever my co-worker
it is more powerful to say to god father
you
said in psalm 103 verse 3 who forgiveth
all thine iniquities who healeth all thy
diseases
for the you said in exodus 15 26
i am the law that healeth thee father
you said
in exodus 23 25 i will take sickness
away from the midst of thee father you
said in james 5 15
and the prayer of faith shall raise save
the sick and the lord shall raise him up
father you said so you bring
your petitions to god wrapped in god's
word
because god will never deny his word
again let me say quickly using god's
word is not an attempt to manipulate him
we bring to god something that god
cannot deny
it is not by accident that psalm 138
verse 2 says
thou has magnified thy word above all
thy name
the entire universe was by the word of
god by the word of the lord where the
heavens made psalm 33 verse 6
on all the hosts of them by the breath
of his mouth for he spake and it was
done
he commanded and it stood fast verse 9
psalm 33
the word of god created life the word of
god
sustains life the word of god is the
vehicle of forgiveness
the word of god was the means by which
jesus christ cast out demons
matthew 8 16 the word of god is
everything
no wonder the centurion said to christ
lord i am not worthy that thou should
come under my roof
but speak the word only and my servant
shall be healed so what i'm saying to
you is when you pray
pray biblically as when the disciples
prayed in acts 4
23-24 onwards when peter and john were
released
lord why did the heathen rage and the
people imagine a vain thing
what they were praying in acts chapter 4
they were
quoting from psalm 2 why did the heathen
rage
and the people imagine a vain thing the
kings of the earth set themselves
and the rulers take counsel together
against the lord and against his
anointing
they were quoting from well jehoshaphat
who was confronted by three armies in ii
chronicles chapter 20 when he began to
pray he said lord
art not thou god in heaven that's how he
began his prayer
in verse 6 of second chronicles 20 well
that's a biblical prayer
because the bible we pray our father
which art in heaven
and so when he said art not thou god in
heaven
god had to say yes and rule is not thou
over the earth
the bible says that god had to say yes
if you read that prayer
second chronicles 20 verse 6 to 11 all
the way through
as um jehoshaphat is quoting
bible verses and you can almost with the
air of faith hear god say
yes yes yes then hezekiah said
deliver us and of course god said yes
let me say quickly
the word of god does not exist for us to
manipulate god
it shows our dependence our reliance
our faith in the word of god
by the way when you pray in the name of
jesus you're praying through the word of
god
because jesus says i am the way the
truth and the life
that's john 14 6 and john 17 17 says
thy word is truth so jesus is the word
revelation 19 13
and he was clothed with a vesture dipped
in blood and his name
is called the word of god john 1 1 in
the beginning was the word
and the word was with god and the word
was god john 1 14
the word became flesh so when we pray in
the name of jesus
we ought to pray through the word of god
what am i trying to tell you when you
pray
pray earnestly you've been studying for
admission to medical school
you've taken certain studies now you're
about to sit your exam
you've studied hard you've done your
best you go to god you don't say
casually father if it's okay with you
let me pass
no you pray as is this as if it is a
matter of life and death
or you failed an exam and they're about
to throw you out of the university
but you realize that it was an anomaly
you're not that kind of student
you need a second chance to demonstrate
that you're truly a gifted
you pray and you pray earnestly
like hannah like hezekiah
like jesus like jacob
pray without ceasing
pray all during the day and let me say
again
this is not symbolic language
pray about everything and my prayer i
don't mean father i come to you in the
name of jesus no not that let me tell
you something i do
it's just personal i drive a car called
a hyundai
and so every day where am i wherever i
am i pray for
all people in hyundai's i don't know who
they are
and i say two things father take them
safely
and take present truth to them if
they've never heard it
every single day
i pray for people driving the hyundai
now the car i had before the hyundai was
a subaru and so i pray every day
for people driving a subaru so this
gives me one reason to constantly pray
because when i'm driving around
all i see are subarus and hyundai's and
a car my wife drives a gmc
and i pray for people in those cars so i
have
reason to pray i fly a lot
every day i pray for planes that are
flying overhead
very often in my flight i have seen
people
taken ill on planes i have seen people
collapse
in the eye just fall down collapse and
the stewardess of the flight attendant
had to say
is there a doctor on board is there a
nurse on board and i've been on flights
that had to be diverted to other cities
because people got so sick and so every
day i pray
not only for the safety of passenger
planes i pray that if someone has taken
ill on a plane
that god in this mercy will stabilize
that person
that the plane might continue his
journey and the person received proper
treatment at the end of that journey
find reasons to pray every time
i see someone on a motorcycle i pray
because they're so vulnerable there's
some protection in the car
with a motorcycle going at 100
kilometers per hour you hit a tree you
are dead
in a very worst way i pray for them
there's another prayer i offer every day
during the day
and i say lord under every heading of
human suffering
deliver someone right now right now is
not a command to god i'm being specific
lord under every heading of human
suffering you know someone's about to be
raped
someone's about to be brutalized a
little child is about to be sodomized
some captive soldiers about to be
tortured someone is suffering
and i ask god deliver someone right now
or someone's there are people in prison
and they're innocent
every day i try to remember father there
are
innocent people in prison you are not a
god
a false imprisonment your god of justice
bring them out they god
bring them out and i always say to god
begin with
members of the household of faith and
then move on to others
find reasons to pray every time i see an
old person leaning on a stick
can hardly walk in and out of the
supermarket i pray for that person what
am i saying to you
find reasons to pray all during
the day pray without ceasing
and pray with determination remember
jesus
he went again and prayed the third time
saying the same word keep your petition
before god
but remember john 15 7. if he abide in
me
and my words abide in you your prayer
must not
circumvent the bible no aspect of the
believer's life
can get around the bible because it is
by the word
and so i leave you with a review
pray earnestly who are your examples
well at the top is jesus
hebrews 5 7 hannah first samuel 1 verse
hezekiah isaiah 38
1-3 pray jacob
genesis 32 pray earnestly and do not
give up
pray without ceasing find reasons to
pray
when you see a tree thank god for
vegetation
you may not see too much in perhaps in
botswana there's a country
but um you'll see something you'll see
animals pray and thank god
that he's the god of nature he's a god
of creation
and he's the god of salvation pray
and for his determination keep your
requests
before god keep your requests before god
and the study of the word as the word
gets
into you the word serves as an internal
director
of your prayers to suggest no don't pray
for that but pray for this
i thank god this night of prayer
sponsored by the youth department
at the south botswana conference i hope
something was said
that will remain with you
now is a good time it's almost bedtime
where you are in some countries on the
african continent or wherever you may be
it's still
it's just about uh minutes after 4am
make a commitment recommit your life to
god
right where you are it does not take
long to say father i recommit my life to
you direct me
guide me help me to live by every word
that proceeds from your mouth
and these are the words that proceed
from the mouth of god recommit your life
to god and if you're not the seventh
evidence and you're listening make a
decision right now to be baptized
it does not mean you'll be baptized
today but preparations can be made
listen to me carefully
make a decision right now tell god
father i'm willing to be baptized
god loves a willing heart tell him i am
willing to be baptized and god will
guide your steps
and let's make prayer the breath
of our souls let's pray father in heaven
thanks again for this moment of prayer
thank you for your people who've stayed
from beginning to end
thank you god for listening to us thank
you for preserving the equipment
so that there was no major malfunction
and thank you thank god for the
privilege
of praying to the great god of the
universe father
i suspect none of us listening has ever
sat down next to our country's leader
whether prime minister or president or
whomever
but weak in jesus dear god we can come
and
sit next to you or kneel before you and
talk to you
it is an honor that god it is a
privilege thank you
help us to use it more frequently father
because the more we pray the more we
suggest
our need of you dear god again i ask you
if we've offended you
forgive us father forgive us cleanse us
and grant us more of your grace move
your spirit
work through us to bring the light of
truth to others
if little boys or little girls have
listened bless them in a very special
way that god because we know
little children learn a lot although
they may not say anything
nowadays wrap your arms around your
people worldwide
draw us to your bosom father and keep us
in the safety
of your bosom as your word says he that
dwelleth in the secret place
of the most high shall abide under the
shadow of the almighty
let your bosom be our abiding place save
us when you come to god
without losing one in jesus name i pray
amen
you